this is tomorrow saying reading for
reviewer steve watts in warrior ware get
it together wario loosely goes back to
his platforming roots and brings his own
original characters along for the ride
it's a much different warrior way
experience and the new twist is mostly
for the better
if you played any prior warrior aware
games you have a basic idea of what to
expect and get it together wario and his
cadre of weirdos have created a series
of micro games that only last a handful
of seconds you'll find yourself plopped
into a game screen with an instruction
consisting of no more than a few words
meaning you have to figure out the goal
and execute the right action with quick
thinking and sharp reaction times these
micro games are then thrown into a
blender demanding quick responses one
after another in a gauntlet of zany
action it's a formula that has been fun
since mega micro games on the game by
advance and it still works exceptionally
well and maybe even better with this new
take on the concept the twist in get it
together is that all of the micro games
involve some degree of character
platforming while previous warioware
games may have simply had you press the
a button at the right moment to
manipulate an on-screen device and get
it together you'll always be controlling
a character characters include wario
complete with his wario land style
shoulder slam along with the warioware
specific characters who have been
introduced throughout the series is
history as a story device they've all
been sucked into their own video game
which is being plagued by bugs each of
the characters controls fairly
differently within a few broad
archetypes some like wario dribble and
spitz and obelon are hovering characters
who can move freely but have different
functions like the aforementioned
shoulder charge firing a cannon or
extending a tractor beam young cricket
is more of a traditional platforming
character who can walk along the ground
and jump
[Music]
9-volt continuously skateboards back and
forth and fires his yo-yo straight
upwards to knock away enemies and
obstacles and to grab onto grapple
points
[Music]
similarly his older brother 18 volt is
stationary with an omnidirectional
firing ability that can also cling onto
grapple points
[Music]
wario's colorful cast is really brought
to life here with new 3d models that
maintain the look of the sprite-based
artwork of their original incarnations
while animating more fluidly more
significantly this character approach
has a major impact on gameplay
introducing an entirely new layer to the
tried and true recipe for the warioware
series now on top of quickly
interpreting a goal and reacting your
brain also needs to process which
character you're using and how their
unique abilities can accomplish that
goal one might need you to jump over an
obstacle to reach an object so quickly
assessing that goal will be different
for a hover character than a grapple
character
this is a neat and altogether welcome
change that makes the micro games that
much more complex and satisfying by
forcing your brain to do two things at
once as always sometimes the
instructions are too vague so it will
take a few attempts to understand what
you are even supposed to do the more
severe problem and an obvious drawback
to this character-based system is that
some characters just aren't well suited
to the goals of a stage get it together
even openly recognizes this if you go to
take on an individual mission through
the playofedia you'll see the individual
characters rated for the task on a scale
from bad fit with an angry red face to
good fit with a happy green face the
worst of the offenders is 9-volt whose
combination of fast skateboarding and
yo-yo grappling means he's rarely the
ideal character to tackle a task there
are some in which he's acceptable but 9
volt cannot be good he can only suck
less
having one particular character so
poorly equipped for handling these
challenges means he sticks out and i
always felt a little pang of frustration
when i saw he was queued up for the next
micro game to an extent this is just an
inevitable outcome of this new approach
when the central hook revolves around
randomly pairing differentiated
characters and tasks you're going to get
a bad match once in a while but knowing
that on an intellectual level doesn't
keep it from feeling unfair when you
randomly get assigned a character who is
poorly equipped for a micro game only to
spend your last life and fail out of
your run still the frenetic pace of
constantly dealing with your new micro
games means that if you flub one you're
off to the next and having fun before
you can even take a breath
yes
piece of cake
let's go
[Music]
find ghost
[Music]
the main story is low impact and
forgiving too most of the areas require
you to complete between 10 and 20 micro
games without four failures but even if
you do fail it lets you spend a pittance
of in-game currency to just continue
instead of starting over from scratch
the story campaign is how you're
introduced to all of the characters and
extra modes so it's worth it to get
through that content without fuss so you
can move on to the post game which is
where warioware games find the most
longevity at their core warioware games
are score challenges the wealth of micro
games means you'll be encouraged to rack
up a high score both in ever harder and
ever faster versions of individual games
back to back and mixes of the games
running through story stages a few more
times will help fill out the playopedia
with all of the micro games and since
you unlock new characters throughout the
campaign going back to old stages will
also let you use new mixes of characters
you can choose to play as one particular
character thus assuring you always have
the ideal match for a task and know
exactly what to expect
hand select a crew of three or toss
caution to the wind and go with a mix of
every unlocked character
[Music]
for obvious reason choosing all is the
most challenging way to go but a mission
system rewards you for being daring that
area has an array of goals to complete
from reaching certain score targets to
unlocking all of the game types in a
certain area to completing stages with
all characters your reward for these are
play coins the same ones that let you
continue after failing out in the story
campaign in the post game coins are
mostly used to buy prezis gifts you can
give your characters to level them up
you can buy them directly from a shop
that refreshes on a timer or use a gacha
style capsule machine to get a random
assortment of gifts
different characters like different
gifts and leveling them up with prezis
unlocks new job titles and cosmetics for
them during the review phase i dumped
all of my prezzies into wario attempting
to see how high the leveling system goes
it appears to go up to level 30 with
stacking prestige levels after that so
reaching that point with all of the
characters will keep you occupied for
quite some time completing the story
campaign unlocks the variety pack while
a few are new mini-games unique to the
mode and slightly larger than the micro
games that comprise the main game most
of the two to four player modes are
different iterations of micro game mixes
that means that there isn't quite as
much variety in the variety pack as it
first appears but the story is all
available with two players as well
effectively doubling your characters
while the story missions feel generally
balanced on their own in single player
it's a little easier and more fun to
manage the hectic action with a partner
the pulse game also includes the wario
cup a weekly challenge that awards big
payouts and if you have a switch online
subscription ranks you against other
players worldwide the weekly warrior cup
during the review period was a remix of
story campaign stages with an extra
twist like completing a predetermined
lineup of stages as a super fast nine
volt related nine volt is the worst for
the most part the new character based
approach is a welcome addition to the
warioware blueprint the characters
themselves are differentiated and
expressive and mechanically they make
the traditional micro game challenges
that much more engaging the warioware
series has been fertile ground for
nintendo to experiment with concepts
like touchscreen capabilities in touch
or accelerometer based motion in twisted
which makes get it together's
platforming riffs a little more
traditional than usual but that also
makes it less reliant on a gimmick and
that's a change for the better
[Music]
spin it